I read you a portion of Jim Sue hands
column in the Minneapolis star-tribune
pretty ominous there in the gym joining
us this morning do you solve all your
problems Jim by firing your offensive
coordinator oh god no no no they have
offensive line problems they have a Kirk
Cousins problem they have a high
expectations problem I understand why
they fired John at this point because
they John and Zimmer were not getting
along and we're seeing eye-to-eye
things weren't functioning Kevin
Stefanski is a very talented young guy
who probably should have gotten the job
to begin with and this gives him a shot
for him to try to prove he can he can
work some magic there so I understand
the move short term but big term they
have much bigger problems okay you
talked about Kirk D cousins and he sort
of shrinks when the spotlight gets right
or brightest how do you fix that that
that's exactly my point is that if Kirk
isn't going to play better in big games
than nothing else really max and they
might be it might be blowing up the
entire operation here hey listen I was I
was Pro Kirk Cousins I was in favor of
them signing him I thought he played
great up through there by week
he's very accurate he can put up a big
game he you know he has a pretty he had
a pretty good bond with these receivers
hey everything was pretty good and then
they come out of the Buy and they go to
Chicago and he doesn't look like he's
comfortable I'm trying to you choose my
words very cautiously here you did not
look comfortable making but if the Bears
right so you maybe give him a pass and
then the last two games at New England
in the afternoon and then at Seattle on
Monday nights two defenses that are
pretty good pretty good at preventing
points but tend to give up a lot of
yards they're not the hardest defenses
to operate against and you know the
alarm bell started going off cousins
just I mean again to choose my words
carefully he did not look comfortable in
these situations he did not look he was
and you know first glance you're
watching and say okay maybe nobody's
open maybe the office line isn't giving
the chance then you look back and there
are receivers open he's not seeing them
or he's reacting to not only real
pressure but phantom pressure
you just can't have that that's not
gonna work it feels like they don't know
what their identity is oh no offense
well I think that's part of the D
Philippa Zimmer dynamic Zimmer is an
old-school Parcells type guy he wants
them to rumble and let's face it in the
modern NFL teams really don't run the
ball that much you try to run it
effectively but you don't just stand
there and hand it off first and second
down and face third and six nobody does
that
so Zimmer wants that old-school
mentality and he once cooked down would
cook to be more involved and be
philipose like that's just not what
we're doing here we have two great
receivers we have just signed this you
know a very expensive quarterback you
got to throw it around and that wasn't
gonna be a resolved between those two we
were just talking about this prior to
you coming on did you have an offensive
coordinator in john d filippo who wants
to be the next sean McVeigh and he's
gonna be the next head coach and waiting
here and this is how I showcase my
talents by having this wide open offense
here and throwing the ball 40 times a
game that is exactly right
John's a very smart guys very ambitious
guy I think he thought it takes I have
one good season with the Vikings I'm the
next as you said next Shawn the kadai
and Zimmer's like you know I don't care
about your resume I want to see Dalvin
cook running between the tackles and you
know listen as we know those those
dynamics can work when the team's
winning as soon as they started losing
as soon as cousins started looking
uncomfortable it was very obvious to
everyone around the teams those two
we're not getting along how much heat
his cousins getting local radio fan
reaction you know I think that I think
these blame is being spread between the
offensive line which is also a way to
blame Ric Stillman for not improving the
offensive line Cousins and D Flippo
analyst let's be honest the go-to move
for every NFL fan is to blame the
coordinator right they always should run
if they pass they always should have
passed me right you know at some point
at some point you do need over the hint
you can't have 62 trick plays a game you
do have to once a lot hand the ball off
in gain yardage you do everyone still
have to run a conventional pass play and
have the quarterback stand in the pocket
Nick Pass
you know I I listen I get Shermer a lot
of credit he was it he he did he work
magic last year but even then you have
to be able to run some basic plays once
in a while you know you have to have the
offensive line function you have to have
have to have the quarterback stain of
the pocket once a while well they still
have a chance a good chance to make the
playoffs yeah all right so I mean they
they should I would say they should be
the sixth seed and then they have and
then that'll be the interesting things
what how does cousins react if he has to
go play in Chicago in January in the
first round of the playoffs if the
Vikings don't make the playoffs
dot-dot-dot the Wilfs have been very
stable owners they were very kind of
impetuous when they first took over the
team the first couple years a little
wild they've really been stable in
patient I can't tell you that they're
gonna fire people if they don't make the
playoffs but you know but you this is
Zimmer six years playoff record is one
and two they've won two playoff games
his franchise has since 2004 one of them
was with Brett Favre and the other one
was on a play we call miracle so if the
Wilfs are really thinking it's time to
win a Super Bowl with this group of
players and he gets at that point and
that's your coach's record and mr.
general matters his record I think
they'd at least have to consider making
a move
Jim thanks for joining us should be
interesting three weeks here in mini
Minnesota yes sir thank you all right
Minneapolis star-tribune columnist Jim
sue in for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]